foreign
technology plays a central role in
medical activities nevertheless the
healthcare technology industry is
fragmented in Europe especially when it
comes to rules and operational standards
across the continent the consequence
businesses selling the Machinery have a
limited ability to operate as part of a
single Market integrating the healthcare
Enterprises among the initiatives
helping the health sector to better
connect with the market the ihe helps
provide rules that allow clinicians
industry and patients to share
information
[Music]
in Montrose Switzerland an international
event called connectathon has gathered
various different actors from the health
sector to discuss common challenges they
face and test their Health Products
their experience is also being
considered for the implementation of the
upcoming European health data space
the industry through its products acts
as a bridge between legislation and the
users of clinical data whether they are
patients or doctors
Synergy happens when institutions adopt
interoperability Frameworks based on
International standards
foreign but there are several challenges
facing European National Healthcare
Systems here for example we see a
patient who regularly undergoes heart
checkups the problem is that the results
are often not shared between the
different Healthcare centers
ihe proposes a partnership between users
suppliers and Healthcare establishments
to set up protocols explaining how
Health Data should be shared
[Music]
however creating such an interconnected
framework is a complex task indeed
so let's see how it works thanks to the
explanation of a Swiss cyber health
expert
[Music]
there are several challenges the first
is to establish a legal basis to allow
the exchange of Health Data the sharing
of documents so that the patient can
control who will access it
then we have the technical questions to
understand how the different systems
will exchange and communicate with each
other and this is where ihe plays an
important role by providing the
standards to enable this
interoperability in digital Health
standards and interoperability are
critical to help the system run properly
and provide patients with quality Care
standards or a set of rules that enable
communication between the health systems
while interoperability means exchanging
data in a coordinated manner
at the Swiss connectathon event dozens
of medical products and software tested
by ihe experts to verify if they match
with protocols set up in several domains
such as Radiology Cardiology patient
care coordination and laboratory
medicine for instance
[Music]
the software creators taking part in the
event aim to test the exchanges between
their system and the other software
systems which are modeled on real use
cases
when it comes to authorizing access to
Patient Health Data I.T experts foresee
a case-by-case option
we can imagine that consent will be by
default and then it will be up to the
patient to decide which health
professional has access to which data on
the other hand a patient could say I
don't want my data to be accessed unless
I'm admitted to the emergency room and
they really need to access it to treat
me
the European health data space
initiative will add momentum to the
digital transformation of the Healthcare
Systems moreover in that new scenario
sharing data with digital Health
companies will help to deliver more
patient-centered Healthcare Solutions
foreign